let's get the perspective of Senator
Mike Lee of Utah whose new book out in
paperback just today is already a huge
New York Times bestseller it's on my
facebook and website written out of
history that forgotten founders who
fought big government
welcome senator as always it's great to
see you
I think our founders would be shocked to
see what's happened to this country
obviously a whole different situation in
our country's founding but you heard
this debate we just had you heard the
statistics President Obama said these
people are gonna have to go home then
they all get to stay they're relocated
to sponsor senator and then we're trying
to we're trying to check on them the
sponsors a lot of them are going on you
know off the grid because they don't
want to be deported they don't want the
kids to be deported so it's all it's a
perverse system we've set up that's
exactly what's bringing these people
here that's exactly why these children
are being separated from their parents
because we had a government that refused
to enforce the law and a government that
said we will deport you and then didn't
when that happens you end up being a
magnet for illegal immigration that
subjects all kinds of children to
exploitation to abuse to sexual assault
in many cases but make no mistake that
is the cause approximately 90% of all
removal orders that means deportation
orders each year result from a failure
of for people to show up at their
hearings so they're there their order
removed because they don't show up for
their actual immigration hearings that's
90% of the unaccompanied minors are not
showing up at hearings so they come here
they know they're gonna be able to stay
here what is the Senate and the house
cooking up I keep hearing about the
administration's gonna come out and
agree to an amnesty with an end to chain
migration kind of sounds like good lad
but it's not quite the gut Bob Goodlatte
bulb bill what's going on there I would
love to see it be there Bob good luck
bill I think Bob Goodlatte has done a
remarkable job of balancing various
competing interests I hope they're not
coming up with something like what they
cooked up in 2013 remember how they told
us they were coming up with a deal it
was rumored for many months years in
fact that they were working on it and
they finally released it and it was
about a thousand pages worth of
something that nobody had read people
voted for it anyway and then they
switched it when it when it got to a
final vote and replaced it with a
different 1,200 page bill I fear here
they might be doing the same thing and I
think they should remember the concept
once of that freedom caucus doesn't want
it they've already come out and said
your day Bradley discuss we don't want
it we don't want an amnesty but can you
get something positive me if you could
end this chain migration that is a huge
amplifier of immigration in the country
non merit-based that would be a big
that's that's a bigger driver of the
growth and immigration is it not than
even illegal immigration absolutely
absolutely and that's one of the things
I like about the Goodlatte proposal is
that it addresses that it addresses the
daca situation it does so in a
responsible manner that shuts off the
magnet I want to ask you about this
other news over the last few days that
when is spying spying your colleague
Marco Rubio said something I think
interesting on ABC's this week I'd like
your reaction let's watch it appears
that there was an investigation not of
the campaign but of certain individuals
who have a history that we should be
suspicious of that predate the
presidential campaign of 2015 2016 the
FBI who is in charged of
counterintelligence investigations
should look at people like that but
they're not investigating the campaign
they're investigating those people so
you're saying President Trump was wrong
I have seen no evidence that there that
those people were a part of an
investigation on the campaign his final
statement might be true as far as it
goes he may have seen no evidence of any
spying on the Trump campaign it doesn't
mean it didn't happen and I I think it's
very difficult to prove that a dog
didn't bark I don't think he's saying
the dog didn't bark what he's saying he
hasn't it seems like Rubio you got it
would play a sound bite later on from
trey Gowdy there are a lot of
Republicans who seem to be working
overtime a lot of them didn't support
the president working overtime to you
know build up Bob Muller the Bob Muller
team and I think that from the very
beginning there have been a lot of
people who have been very surprised
about that senator it's great to see it
was always Congrats on the book great
great read